[Music]
slow and steady wins the race
unlocked too fast before enough of us
are vaccinated
and this virus could get ahead of us
again two days provide a very high
degree of
protection against serious illness and
death
but there are still millions of younger
adults who have not been vaccinated
and sadly a proportion of the elderly
and vulnerable
may still succumb even if they have had
two jabs that's why we're so concerned
by the delta variant that is now
spreading faster
than the third wave that was predicted
in the february
road map an end to restrictions on our
lives was due in a week's time
it's now not going to happen instead a
four-week delay to give the vaccine
rollout time to catch up
with the virus i'm confident that we
will not need
more than four weeks and we won't need
to go beyond july the 19th
we will monitor the position every day
and if
after two weeks we have concluded that
the risk has diminished
then we reserve the possibility of
proceeding
to step four and a full opening sooner
by being cautious now we have the chance
in the next four weeks
to save many thousands of lives
by vaccinating millions more people
but not every life will be saved no one
thinks at the end of the four-week delay
the risk is gone there will still be
substantial numbers there will be
substantial numbers in hospitals
and sadly there will be some people who
will go on to die of this
the question is a matter of balance in
exeter people are prepared to slow down
if it means we won't have to go
backwards we don't want another lockdown
basically
so you're quite relaxed if you can't go
clubbing and you can't
pile into a pub and yeah it's not too
bad
there are a lot of people that are that
are moaning about it but
it's a safety issue at the end of the
day yeah it is frustrating i won't deny
that but
if it's if it's better for people and
um in the long run it will make
like things will turn out better then
yeah i don't mind
so-called freedom day is off and while
many people will understand why the
prime minister took that decision
many businesses will nevertheless be
hugely disappointed that they cannot
fully reopen but this pm would rather be
mr delay now
than mr reverse in a few weeks time
it's been a long 15 months and the
battle against covid
not over yet we're going to have to live
with the virus forever but the vaccine
at least means that restrictions will
come to an end
july the 19th now the terminus date for
this
road map but uncertainty still about
what life looks like
beyond beth rigby sky news